la rencontre entre les deux rivaux aura
t elle lieu cette fois-ci le chef du
gouvernement d'union nationale fayez al
sa rage et l'homme fort de l'est libyen
le maréchal khalifa haftar devraient
être tous les deux présents à la
conférence internationale qui se tient à
berlin aujourd'hui un rendez-vous qui
intervient moins d'une semaine après
celui de moscou organisée sous l'égide
de la russie et de la turquie
vladimir poutine a confirmé sa présence
dans la capitale allemande pour un
sommet qui va se dérouler sur fond de
craintes d'une internationalisation du
conflit
du côté de moscou on tient à rappeler
que la relation entre al ça réagit
haftar reste très tendue le spectre
après la conférence de berlin
si le conseil de sécurité soutient sa
décision il faut enfin que les parties
libyennes ne répète plus leurs erreurs
de l'époque ne s'accuse pas pour
l'instant les six libyenne dans des
conflits troncs des relations très
tendues ne veulent pas même être présent
dans la même salle
alors avec nos collègues italiens nous
allons participer à cette conférence
j'ai prévu rencontre à berlin avec le
ministre dit maillot la grèce qui n'a
pas été conviée à cette conférence
internationale a reçu à la surprise
générale khalifa haftar arrivé jeudi
soir dans le pays
le ministre grec des affaires étrangères
nicos dendias a encouragé le maréchal
libyen à participer au sommet de berlin
dans un esprit constructif afin
d'essayer d'obtenir un accord formel de
cessez-le-feu ainsi que le
rétablissement de la sécurité en libye
cette visite est intervenue alors que la
grèce n'a cessé de renforcer ses liens
avec l'opposant gouvernement d'union
nationale une invitation critiqué par la
turquie qui estiment qu'elle sabotent
les efforts de paix l'entrevue d'athènes
a eu lieu notamment après la signature
d'un accord maritime controversée entre
ankara et le camp de fayez al sa rage
notre position européenne commune
reconnaît la nullité absolue et
l'inexistence des mémorandum signé entre
le gouvernement sa rage et la turquie
j'ai dit au général haftar que la grèce
était prête à aider en libye avec la
participation à une trêve
ou encore avec l'envoi des forces
grecques dans le cercle européen afin
d'imposer un embargo sur les transferts
d'armes et de mercenaires vers la libye
pour rappel les forces du maréchal
haftar ont lancé en avril 2019 une
offensive contre tripoli pour s'opposer
notamment aux milices djiadistes
présente dans la capitale libyenne
plus de 284 civile ainsi que 2000
combattants ont été tuées depuis selon
l'onu quelque 146 mille libyens ont
quant à eux dû fuir les combats
[Musique]